inflation is really just another tax
because governments create inflation
inflation is also probably one of the
most misunderstood words in the English
language and deliberately so I think
governments around the world kind of led
the campaign to redefine inflation so if
you go back to the origin of the word
and if you if you have a dictionary even
from the 1980s a Webster's dictionary
you'll get the real definition of
inflation so inflation is an expansion
of the money supply that's all it is
deflation is a contraction of the money
supply so if you even think about the
word inflate inflate is to expand like a
balloon if you if you fill a balloon
with air it expands so with inflation
what's being expanded is the money
supply who expands the money supply
governments